when someone studies Jesus you fall in
love with him when you look to
Christians you hate
Christianity and then I have one more
question for you uh this is just
something like I've thought about um how
do you have like uh any resource I can
look into or or do you have like any
insight onto the origin of evil like how
did Sin first
propagate uh in a nutshell I don't know
which can recommend in the N nutshell it
was Satan that introduced sin into the
world
because remember the serpent tempted
Adam and Eve so human sin was passed on
by Adam and Eve but the original sinner
was the serpent Satan he was the one who
committed the first sin because what is
sin in 1 John CH
3:4 1 John chapter 3:4 it says sin is
breaking the command of God sin is
lawlessness breaking his command so the
first sinner the first one to disobey
God in his order is the serpent meaning
Satan and you know where you find this
tght
explicitly here's here's the advantage
of reading the DOR chonicles if you go
with just the Protestant Canon 39 Old
Testament books 27 New Testament books
the first reference to the serpent being
Satan is in Revelation
12:9 right okay if I were to just go
with the shorter Cannon 39 Old Testament
books 27 New Testament books I would not
know that that the serpent is the devil
until I get to Revelation it's in
Revelation
12:9 where we're told that ancient
serpent is the devil but if you read the
dter
chonicles in wisdom chapter 2 verses 22
to 24 we're told that the serpent who
caused Adam and Eve to sin was the devil
and he did it out of Envy so we're told
that Satan's sin was Envy here let me
show it to
see the advantage guys Protestants
you're listening the advantage of having
the larger Cannon you'll find
information there that you don't find in
the shorter Canon here it is wisdom
chapter 2 verses 22 to 24 here it is
wisdom of Solomon which is part of the
Orthodox Canon and the Catholic Cannon
but it's not part of the Protestant
Cannon here it
is chapter 2 of wisdom of Solomon verses
22 to 24 and they did not know the
secret purposes of God this is talking
about those who ended up killing the Son
of God which by the way there's a
prophecy here which I'll read a little
later nor hope for the wages of Holiness
nor disum the prize for blaming souls
for God created man for
incorruption so God didn't create you to
die God didn't create
you to be mortal he created you to be
immortal and Incorruptible that's right
here see for God created man for in in
corruption and made him in the image of
his own eternity so he made you to be
Eternal like him so then why do you die
but through the devil's Envy death
entered the world and those who belong
to his party experience it so right
there you're told that serpent was the
devil who out of envy and hatred towards
humans tempted them to sin so they would
die so evil came from Satan disobeying
God because God chose humans to be the
crown of his creation and that caused
them to be
envious I I correct me if I'm wrong I
believe there might be a verse that that
like references us judging the Angels
does that mean angels have have free
will and can sin yes 1 Corinthians
chapter 6 veres 2 to3 is what you're
referring to where Paul says do you not
know we will judge the world that we
will judge Angels yes we will judge
Angels because if Spirit creatures were
not endowed with the ability to choose
then Satan could not have chosen to
rebel against God and demons could not
have chosen to rebel against God because
demons and Satan were not created evil
they were created good they were good
spirit creatures but he endowed them as
he endowed us with the ability to choose
this is the problem I see in Calvinism
because they they think that you can
only choose based on the desires that
God has given to you but then how did
Satan choose to sin that's that must
mean God gave saying desire which is
nonsense so and another thing calvinist
actually yeah it is but calvinist will
tell you well Adam and Eve were
initially created in such a way created
such a way that they could choose to
obey God or disobey God so they had that
ability but once they sin their nature
is corrupted and all of us are born with
a corrupt nature where we can only
choose to sin but then you test them a
little further say okay so you're saying
Adam and Eve when they were created they
truly had this ability to obey God or
disobey God because the argument of
Calvinism is that once Adam and Eve sin
they corrupted their nature and now they
pass on a corrupt human nature to their
descendants so that you and I because
now we have a corrupt nature we cannot
help but sin and we cannot choose the
things pleasing to God but that wasn't
true of Adam and Eve but then you press
them on it say hold on even though Adam
and Eve had this ability to choose God
or disobey God because their nature had
not been corrupted could they have
chosen not to sin against God no because
everything is causely determined so God
had already causely determined that Adam
and Eve would disobey God that the
serpent would disobey God but if you ask
them so did God make them sin no they
freely sinned but could they have chosen
not to sin no because God had determined
it double speak yeah you took the words
out of my mouth
took the words out so excellent
observation but I don't know in your
situation brother I don't know I don't
want to rush you to become Orthodox or
Catholic but at the same time you are
depriving yourself of the sacraments so
I want to yeah I don't want to rush
either but I at the same time I think I
shouldn't be out of a
church so go to one of the churches or
both and tell them your predicament if
there's an Orthodox Church then look I'm
on a journey and I know it's the
Orthodox or the Catholic church I know
it's one of the other I haven't decided
because I want to make sure I'm making
the right choice but I'm deprived of the
sacraments what would you advise me to
do go there go to local bishop and ask I
don't know I don't know really I don't
know what today I know it's your
situation is is not ideal I don't know
what else I can tell you brother okay
another question um is there like in the
in the Bible um this is something I'm
curious about like the angels being able
to sin what's there to like be uh where
where do they get their forgiveness from
do they also get that from Christ oh yes
you ask an excellent question the Bible
as far as Satan and demons are concerned
there are no forgiveness for them
they're assigned to destruction yeah so
when you say where do they get their
forgiveness well the angels that are
standing before God they have not
sinned so you want to make a distinction
between breaking God's command
intentionally which Michael and Gabriel
do not do now does that mean they're so
faithful to God they've now reached a
point of becoming morally Incorruptible
I really don't know I don't know because
I know in the age to come a new Heaven
earth when we are resurrected and
glorified bodies we will be
made such transformed in such a way
where we will no longer be able to
corrupt ourselves by sinning that's in
the age to come we will be changed to be
morally Incorruptible physically
Immortal this is what the Orthodox call
theosis we will be partakers of the the
nature of God in that regard and that
like God will will be morally
Incorruptible like God we will be
physically Immortal now has Michael
reached a point of obedience where now
God has rewarded him with moral
incorruptibility
or is that something that awaits the new
heaven new Earth I don't know the Bible
doesn't say but I do know that Michael
and Gabriel if they were to sin then
they would be condemned but I also know
from Revelation Michael remains faithful
to the end because Michael will be the
one who will bar Satan from having
access to
heaven so I these are things that I'm
not certain of the answer answer because
the Bible is not clear on giving me the
answer now I don't know how the church
fathers wrestle with that issue because
the Bible is clear on this the more you
do something the more you engage in
something the more it becomes sick
nature so it's no longer something you
do something you choose it's something
it chooses for you in other words it
becomes so ingrained in your DNA it's
now instinctive and that's not just true
with moral choices in every field of
discipline what is the one thing they
keep hammering repetition right like in
martial arts or boxing they keep
hammering repetition keep doing the
techniques over and over again because
you want to drill it in your neuros
system where now you don't have to try
to hit you just do it instinctively it
becomes second nature well in the
spiritual realm when it comes to
spiritual matters when you do something
so repetitive
it becomes so ingrained and engraved in
you that it's no longer something you
choose it's something you do
instinctively as second nature now have
the APO the Angels reached that level of
being so faithful to God where now they
are so righteous it's now second nature
to them they're not able to become
unrighteous I don't
know so where where the Bible is silent
I have to be silent and I don't know how
the church fathers wrestle with that
grappled with that because if Satan was
an angel or a spirit creature and the
demons are angels that means they were
created righteous and morally upright
but they were endowed with the ability
to sin against God and they did and they
corrupted themselves so wouldn't that
also apply to G Michael and Gabriel it
has to so does that mean Michael has a
potentiality of sinning well if they are
endowed with the ability to choose to
obey or Obe God then the answer
theoretically is yes or have they
reached a level of obedience and
righteousness it's now second nature so
they are no longer able to choose to
disobey
perhaps I don't know yeah I see it as
being like you're saying or something
along the lines of being filled with
grace like Mary was right so exactly see
Mary's nature was such God worked on her
nature in such a way where she made free
choices but the free choices she made
were always righteous because her
disposition her inclination was
purified right when people say okay was
Mary forced to say yes to God no she
freely said yes to God because her
nature was such that her choices her
proclivities her desires would always be
right in accord with God's will
so in other words God did for Mary in
advance because she would be the
god-bearer what God will do for the rest
of us in the age to
come okay thank you brother excellent
questions brother you asked excellent
questions I'm proud of you because
you're thinking deeply but go to one of
these church say this is my dilemma what
do I do see what they'll tell you yeah
thank you God bless than you brother